schon seit längerem wissen wir dass die
majestätischen ringe des saturns ihrem
ende entgegengehen
doch das alles passiert in einem viel
schnelleren tempo als bisher angenommen
auf dieses ergebnis kommt ein
forschungsteam der nasa durch die
analyse der planeten atmosphäre und die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sagen auch voraus wann genau der saturn
nackt sein wird was genau passiert mit
den ring und was bedeutet dieser verlust
für den planeten klick zum science
fiction täglich faszinierendes 1 videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen aber
schon in den frühen 80er jahren hatten
die biker sonnen gezeigt dass die ice
teilchen der saturnringe auf den
planeten herabregnen dieses phänomen
kann man sich als staub ähnlichen regen
aus eiskristallen vorstellen deswegen
auch die bezeichnung als ring regen doch
dass der saturn eis und geröll seiner
ringe in einem solch extrem hohen tempo
verliert ist selbst für die fachwelt
eine große überraschung dazu james
o'donnell wie einer der beteiligten
forscher
wir schätzen dass dieser ring regen den
saturn ring in einer halben stunde die
entsprechung eines olympia schwimmbecken
cent zieht nach schätzungen zufolge sind
es pro sekunde etwa 1,5 tonnen masse die
da von den ringen auf dem planeten
herabregnen in 100 millionen jahren
könnten die ringe demnach verschwunden
sein
spätestens aber in 300 millionen jahren
auch wenn das auf den ersten blick nach
einer langen zeit klingt ist es
astronomisch gesehen dagegen eine sehr
überschaubare zeitspanne
dies wird deutlich wenn man sich das
alter des planeten vor augen hält denn
der saturn ist rund vier milliarden
jahre alt äußerst spannend verlief die
analyse des forschungsteams zu den
saturn ring mit einem 10 meter teleskop
des keck observatoriums auf hawaii
suchten sie in der äußeren
atmosphärenschichten des atoms nach den
positiv geladenen hat ryan
sie bestehen aus drei wasserstoffatom
denen ein elektron fehlt doch wie gelang
es den fachleuten damit die rate des
massen verlustes zu ermitteln
vereinfacht gesagt liefert dieses
molekül hinweise auf artikel die mit
extrem hoher energie in die ionosphäre
eingeschlagen sind damit ist die oberen
gas schicht der saturnatmosphäre gemeint
durch die ermittelte menge deshalb 3+
aus dem forschungsteam den massen
verlust in den ring zu ermitteln denn
die emissionen der wasserstoff ionen h3
plus dienen quasi als indikator für den
niederschlag schon seit anfang der 80er
jahre wissen wir übrigens durch die
erkundung der raumsonden voyager 1 und 2
sowie der raumsonde pioneer 11 wie wir
uns die ringe des saturns vorstellen
können entgegen früheren annahmen dass
der planet von nur vier ringen umgeben
ist handelt es sich wohl um etwa 100.000
schmale ringe
die meisten von ihnen sind nur einige
meter dick der dickste von ihnen misst
gerade einmal 100 meter überwiegend
bestehen sie aus bruchstücken von
wassereis sie enthalten aber auch
silikat mineral und andere organische
moleküle rein optisch gesehen wäre das
fehlen der saturnringe die ja quasi das
wahrzeichen des planeten sind ein großer
verlust
denn der markt der planet hat
keinesfalls so spannende farbmuster wie
zum beispiel der jupiter die
wissenschaftswelt geht übrigens davon
aus dass der saturn in früheren zeiten
bereits ohne ringe aus gekommen ist denn
diese sind wohl nicht zeitgleich mit dem
gesamten sonnensystem entstanden sondern
erst später vielleicht sogar erst vor
wenigen hundert millionen jahren durch
eine kollision von asteroiden kometen
und monden so die vermutung zur zeit der
dinosaurier dagegen so das
forschungsteam waren die saturnringe
dagegen deutlich größer und heller als
wir sie heutzutage kennen aber dafür
bekommt ja ein anderer planet in unserem
sonnensystem demnächst ringe klickt hier
auf das video
maas bekommt ring wie saturn top 7
fakten der mond im sonnensystem sehr
sehr spannend und ansonsten bis dann
vielleicht dran